dans le reste de l'actualité d'abord le
procès moussaoui aux etats-unis le jury
américain a rendu un premier verdict le
français est passible de la peine de
mort
attention cela ne signifie pas qu'elle
sera prononcée car une nouvelle étape
judiciaire s'ouvre maintenant en
attendant la maison blanche a déjà
adressé ses félicitations aux jurés sur
place alain de chalvron aranda toute
l'amérique attendait le verdict depuis
mercredi
le voilà le jury a décidé que dans cette
affaire la mort est une sentence
possible
certaines familles de victimes expriment
aussitôt leur satisfaction je suis très
contente de cette décision mais le plus
satisfait c'est sans doute zacarias
moussaoui lui même il a tout fait pour
obtenir ce verdict confirmant dans un
long témoignage tous les arguments de
l'accusation
oui at il dit je faisais partie du
complot du 11 septembre
oui j'ai menti pour que les attentats
puisse avoir lieu
le jury l'a donc entendue en jugeant
qu'il était directement responsable de
la mort de près de 3000 personnes
cet acharnement du français à s'auto
accusé laisse tout de même certaines
familles de victimes sceptique je ne
pense pas que l'exécuter serait bien
c'est ce qu'il veut pourquoi lui faire
ce plaisir
laissons le pourrir en prison quand un
riche à la mère de zacarias moussaoui
elle accepte désormais le choix de son
fils si mon fils il veut pas vivre comme
un lâche
il veut mourir pour six idées idoumou et
b je suis d'accord avec lui
le jury a simplement décidé que zacarias
moussaoui était passible de la peine de
mort il ne l'a pas condamné une deuxième
phase du procès va donc s'ouvrir
maintenant pour voir s'ils peuvent
bénéficier de circonstances atténuantes
et pas de doute que la question de
savoir s'il faut ou non en faire un
martyr sera constamment présente dans
l'esprit des 12 jurés